we're back here with Pepe Julian onziema
the human rights activist from Uganda
let's talk about some of the details of
US influence we saw in the in the
morning breeze clip that you were asked
about recruitment the recruitment that
gays indulge in is this a widely held
belief when you get out of this
recruitment it is and it's caught lovely
that planten's
the whole idea of recruitment in in in
my community in in my society um the
organization that I worked for sexual
minorities Uganda was formed in 2004 and
generally the political social justice
movement around sexual tension and
gender identity began like any 2000
maybe 2000 2001 and the opposition we
were facing at that time did not mention
recruitment it did not mention
pedophilia it did not it was not that of
persecution right
it was just either people ignoring us or
writing glamorous stories about us we
saw a shift in 2007 when we had sort of
a coming-out campaign we had our 45 days
media campaign while we're going to TV
stations doing interviews with the print
media and radio and immediately after we
launched that campaign st. performed
sampai and other religious leaders
including Muslims formed the coalition
the rainbow coalition goes against
homosexual rainbow belongs to God
see the catchy song hateful message
catchy song undeniably catchy tune
there's nothing more dangerous than a
really catchy Jim um but yes that's
that's that's the interesting thing it
wasn't just it in many ways it kind of
United extremist religious groups in
Uganda didn't it's extremist Muslims
extremist Christians they were all
United around the very convenient
scapegoat yes of LGBT members yes they
did and 2009 so from from that time we
kept on seeing this resistance to us and
does this huge backlash in person
leaving the country poor and underground
Mary kept on wacky there's no closure of
offices or raiding of our meetings and
so on and we saw that shift in 2009 much
after that seminar
the seminar was supposed to last for a
week it lasted I think for officially
for two weeks unofficially Scott lively
ones in the country for more than two
weeks a month it was like a hateful
Chanukah it was supposed to last one
week yes did 48 in during this time he
he came with a doctrine that if you
continue allowing activism advocacy
around sexual tension and gender
identity you will have no generation
because homosexuals are here to recruit
your children right this is also coming
from the top down in Uganda cos
President Museveni has argued that the
West has cultivated homosexuality he
called it social imperialism doot-doot
people in Uganda genuinely believe that
we in the West invented homosexuality
and franchised it like a happy meal
yes they well they they really do
President Museveni I think for some time
before he actually signed the law what
we were seeing was a change in his
attitude towards homosexuality he very
many different times say that
homosexuals exist but they've never been
persecuted and the persecution was was
disturbing him he did understand where
that was coming from until I guess when
it became very catchy to continue
persecuting homosexuals in Uganda so he
guess he jumped on the bandwagon as well
uh what what can we do because in the
West we like to think that we have the
solution for anyone's problems overseas
so is there I mean we're trying
sanctions now is there anything sanction
or drawn based that we could do because
we love those because we can do those
from here we can stay and then we can
help you from Utah the u.s. limiting
that was such a long pause that was such
exert at the u.s. look um do you think
the sanctions are do you think the
sanctions are helpful or harmful in my
opinion very harmful larger sample but
very harmful why why so um because I
live on the ground right right I know we
issued guidelines on what people could
do and we're we're divided on this issue
there are people who believe that
sanctions work some believe it won't
work and I'm I'm one of those people who
believes that it doesn't work because
however however targeted it is we're the
ones who end up suffering I'll give you
an example in the in the recent
sanctions there's a aid cut from
community policing royal and we were
trying
you know we had lain late grounds to
engage the police because we know the
police is the immediate violator of LGBT
people arresting when the community call
on them and taking that money away from
them taking away that funding from them
to continue community policing endanger
us why I say that is because in
instances where the community is
attempting mob justice there is like
police everywhere so they come and
intervene I when the intervene the mob
is away they save you for that moment of
course they were taken in custody and
treat you as a homosexual but that
initial reaction is very important it's
very important now let's let's just talk
a little bit more about LGBT issues
across Africa because um the anti-gay
laws are not just in Uganda they've
spread across Africa thirty-seven
African countries now have
anti-homosexuality laws
how did this happen is this a question
of religious principle or is there a lot
of domestic politics going on with this
it's both um actually when you look at
it politics and religion
I like rods so in bed together
there's religion that our communities
hold very very very close when it comes
to other issues from history religion
came from outside Africa but why our
African leaders and Africans mainly
leaders also tightly onto it and then
they say homosexuality that has existed
in Africa for long they say that is from
West it becomes but very but that is the
most demonstrable false thing that could
possibly say no you can't say that there
are there are anthropologists have
pointed out that in pre-colonial times
homosexual marriages were treated as
equal to heterosexual marriages among
the azande people in the Central African
Republic editions don't want to hear
that but in Uganda that will work they
were pre-colonial words in Uganda for
homosexual that were not
derogatory what's clear is that I'm a
president at Chilean Greece the crazy
thing in researching this was realizing
that homophobia is not indigenous to
Africa homosexuality has been there for
let's say ever I was gonna say 200 years
but sure let's isn't your right forever
forever but homophobia has been
introduced later yes I believe that
homophobia is the very thing that is
actually from outside Africa the Bible
came and different things happened
whatever kept us together something had
to be used to to to divide us so that
there's this whole mess within with it
within the Uganda no African settings so
that there's the submission that is is
enforced in people right however much
homophobia came from the West or came
from Britain I think we have to move
beyond blaming people right yeah we've
been educated over the years we we are
learning more about our history and we
know the truth yeah but we are wasting
our potential we are wasting our
intelligence our human resource our
humanity blaming people who have moved
on I think that's a waste of time and we
have to move on
how long have your family been through
this though they have they been they
frightened of your activism have they
been supportive of you my family is
great really that's good
that's uh that's awesome I can't I can't
thank you enough Pepe it's been I've
been Indian researching this story this
week it's because there are really happy
things happening here regarding equality
and it there has been a sad experience
learning uh about our role in this
they're sure there's nothing we can do
you sure just one drum no drugs you just
hand wrong wrong wrong pepper nothing
you've not tried it you can't say that
you're not trending it might help you
doctor we'll get one Joe we're agreed
one drone will try it we'll just try it
for the sake of it Pepe thank you so
much for being with us thank you so much
that was awesome is that what lady